the trump administration is releasing
all coronavirus vaccine doses in the u.s
to help treat the maximum number of
americans and help cannot come soon
enough more than 4 300 americans died
from coronavirus yesterday that is a new
single day record
3000 used to be the record we were
looking at efforts to give out shots are
accelerating all over the country after
repeated criticism that the vaccination
drive
is moving too slowly carter evans is
outside one of those new vaccination
sites the
state farm stadium near phoenix carter
good morning to you
good morning tony the home to the
arizona cardinals is now a 24
7 vaccination site let me show you how
it works the cars
make their way into the parking lot here
they sign in where you see all those red
tail lights over here
and then they make their way over to the
other side those tents
that's where they get the shots more
than 80 000 people have registered so
far
they don't even have to get out of their
car here this is all in a state that is
leading the nation in per capita cases
and hospitalizations hey hi there
how are you guys at state farm stadium
in glendale arizona
the race is on to get as many people
vaccinated as possible
and we are vaccinating you some 3600
people got their covet 19
shots tuesday including the site's
volunteers like kevin ryan
i'm looking forward to the second dose
and
for this thing to be over with the goal
eventually vaccinating twelve
thousand people a day there are probably
some tears of joy when
people get those vaccinations there's
been a lot of gratitude expressed people
are like opening their windows and
clapping
the site which is operating 24 7 opened
monday
one day before the trump administration
announced changes aimed at speeding up
the slow vaccine rollout
every vaccine dose that is sitting in a
warehouse rather than going into an
armed could mean one more life lost the
government will now release
all of its vaccine supply instead of
holding back second doses
officials are now also instructing
states to vaccinate every american
65 and older and adults with
pre-existing conditions
and if states don't use up their doses
quickly enough
they'll lose them we have too much
vaccine sitting in freezers at hospitals
the federal government recommended
putting health care workers at the front
of the vaccination line
which is why early doses were sent to
hospitals
according to a report from the kaiser
family foundation 40 states are still in
the very beginning of the first phase
1a of the vaccination effort inoculating
healthcare workers and people in
long-term care
facilities florida residents adella and
jim bradley say they waited a total of
almost
20 hours in line and were turned away
three times before finally getting their
chance
they were calling him the senior hunger
games
still the couple who are both in their
70s and high risk
say it's worth it now we have hope that
we are able to
go live a more normal life even if we
have to wear masks that's okay
now the vaccinations here are currently
by appointment only though they are
accepting walk-ins when things are slow
they want to keep these vaccinations
moving
now federal officials are also giving
states the go-ahead
to give out the vaccine at more
locations we're talking about
pharmacies and community health centers
that serve low-income communities
gail yeah let's get them out thank you
very much carter